all right everyone I usually don't make
update videos I feel like I'm pretty
terrible at them all right how's it
going everyone I am pumped today because
I recently purchased this bad boy right
here this is the Canon Rebel t2i which
means I'll be getting much better video
quality Bret driver made me film this
video because he's got to be cool if I
opened it on video I hate making update
videos because I'm terrible at them but
let's get started
gotta open this thing I didn't have a
box cutter or anything so I had to use
my samurai sir yeah all right be needing
that later behold the warranty something
some and the instruction guide I'll be
needing that cuz I know nothing about
these cameras alright looks like we got
a little strapped there are people it's
like a USB kind of video thing you got
ourselves a charger battery of course
the USB cable just move all this aside
here and I guess this is the the lens
that comes with we'll just put that guy
right there
Hey
we got care
the Canon Rebel t2i
it's pretty sweet alright that's not it
I got the bundle pack of course so it
came with an extra little something show
this guy opened its nut sliced at Camden
half
yeah oh yeah
zoom lens
um don't know how to work this thing
I'll find out later yeah camera got both
lenses here what I thought yeah I've got
2 8 gigabyte memory cards and I got a
case here and another UV protector
thingamajig so I just thought you know
make this video I guess that means
better picture quality I'm really
excited to learn this thing jump some
new stuff also we have two new things
coming out we have a kind of a little
war scene featuring the tank you know be
secret until it comes out but it's got
the tank and it's kind of cool and then
me and Brett are filming a short film
based on like a guy who steps on a mine
and the whole short film was him trying
to get off of the mine so you know we're
just working on that we're still kind of
writing it shutouts let's see
brent driver of course let's see we got
I want to give a big thanks to Freddie
Wong for telling me about this camera I
was gonna buy the Canon 7d which is like
$1,800 you told me to get this instead
because I you know mostly I do video
stuff I do some picture stuff but he
said if you're doing mostly video you're
gonna want to get this and it saved me
$900 so Thank You Freddie we got Andrew
aka
commander aka subsistence films so check
him out I know there's tons more expect
a little film with this thing soon just
kind of like a little test we've got
some ideas so thank you for watching
this boring video and I'm sorry for
putting you through it